How's it going everyone? In this video,
we are going to be talking about my
favorite fractal model. Specifically, we
are going to talk about the daily for
bias and then using the 4 hour for a
swing point and the 15-minute time frame
for entry. So, let's get into the PDF
and then go into a few Trading View
examples. So the first step is to have a
clear daily bias. Now this doesn't have
to be a candle to closure, but this is
specifically the easiest way to get that
daily bias. So ideally, I'm going to be
looking for a point of interest, either
a low, a high, or a fair value gap. So
you can see in this case, we have a fair
value gap. Then I'll be looking for a
candle to closure inside that fair value
gap. Or for a reversal candle to close
back inside its previous candle's range.
Then I can anticipate price to expand in
the following day. This is the day that
we will be looking to trade in this
candle three looking for this expansion.
So once we have this bias then we're
going to go down to the lower time frame
and use a fractal model to anticipate
this expansion and get on side. So when
we go down to the 4hour time frame this
is what we are going to use for a swing
point as well as the daily profile. Now
our goal is to let the wick of the daily
candle form. So if we are bullish, we
want to see price open, trade lower
first, forming this lower wick. And then
once we anticipate that lower wick to
have formed, then we can look to trade
the body of the candle or this move
higher towards the drawn liquidity. So
how are we going to do this? We're going
to use candle closures. So we are either
going to look for a candle 2 or a candle
3 closure where we anticipate that wick
2 form. So here you can see we have a
candle 2 closure during London. So
paired with our bias, we can anticipate
6 a.m. and 10:00 a.m. to expand higher.
10 a.m. is dependent on 6 a.m. with a
strong closure. We can anticipate it to
move higher. And then we'd only look to
trade this third expansion candle if the
drawn liquidity has yet to be met. So
from here, we're going to look at the
London reversal. So when we have a
candle 2 closure, what do we need to
check for on the lower time frames? A
change in the state of delivery. Now, if
you haven't seen my candle 2 closure
video, this is what we talk about or my
trading candle 3 video. So, here we have
the candle closure, the change in the
state of delivery, and we can anticipate
price to do what? Continue higher in
this next candle at 6:00 a.m. Now, what
do we want to see in this next candle?
We're going to do the exact same thing.
We want to let the wick of this higher
time frame candle form. So, we want to
wait for price to open. Ideally, go make
a low or a low we can trust. Where would
that be? Out of a point of interest. So
you can see how price sweeps out all the
lows to its left into a fair value gap
has a nice V-shaped reversal and a
change in the state of delivery inside
this candle. This means I can anticipate
this wick to have formed and I could
look to get on side here with this
expansion higher. Now what we are doing
here is we are lining up the daily
candle with the lower time frame. Right?
So we let the wick of the daily candle
form looking to trade its body. Then we
do the same thing on the lower time
frame. So, we are trading candle 3es
across multiple different time frames.
And this is what I talk about in my time
frame alignment video. So, you can see
we get the reversal. Here's the
continuation. And this is what I'm
looking to trade. And you can see how
price expands higher. Now, let's get
into trading view and go over a few
examples of this of aligning the daily
with the 4hour and then looking to get
on side using a continuation or a
protected swing on the 15-minute time
frame. Here we are in our first example.
You can see price has entered a fair
value gap and the bodies are still
respecting. Most importantly, we have a
candle to closure on the daily chart
showing that price has reversed in this
candle and we can anticipate price to
expand higher in the next candle ideally
into this fair value gap above and
higher. So now that we have a daily bias
and looking in candle 3 for a move
higher, we can go to the 4hour chart. So
down here on the 4hour chart, the next
thing we are going to want to look for
is a candle 2 closure or where to
anticipate the daily wick to form. So
here you can see right off the open we
have a nice candle to closure which
engulfs the previous down close candle
here. So looking at that as our candle 2
closure, we could be looking for price
to trade higher in candle 3 here to
these failure swings on the left side.
So looking at the daily wick and the
4hour wick, we are aligning all of our
time frames in one singular direction.
So now going down to the 15-minut time
frame. So here we are down on the
15-minut time frame and you can see we
have had that 4hour candle 2 closure. We
have a change in the state of delivery.
So we can be looking bullish in this
candle three on the 4 hour and this is
also the low of the daily candle. Now
some people like to trade this reversal
right here. I personally like to wait
for a continuation. Now, why is that?
Well, let's say price is going to react
in this area. Price is either going to
do that, form a swing low, and then
trade higher, or it is just going to
fall through here. Now, I would rather
just wait for it to react or not react
and save myself a loss than to place a
limit. So, what am I going to be looking
for here? Is a continuation. So, here
you can see we have the down closed
candles into a fair value gap. Can we
get a closure over this area? Well,
let's see.
And you can see we make a new low. So
now we are in a fair value gap sweeping
out a low. We have a new series of down
close candles. So let's see if we get a
nice V-shaped recovery.
We do and we close over. So now using
the 4hour candle 2 closure, I've
anticipated the daily wick to have
formed. And then using the change in the
state of delivery inside this candle 3,
I've anticipated this wick to have
formed. So now that all my time frames
are aligned, I can look for this
continuation entry. My entry is at the
market of the new open. My stop is at
that protected low and then I can look
for 2 R or what can I also do? I can
look for those higher time frame
objectives. So if we zoom out, this
would be our 2R. Or we can look for
these failure swings here which is just
around 4R. So let's see how this works
out.
And there you go. You can see how we hit
RTP. If we go ahead and remove these
drawings here, you can see we also get
another continuation in this candle 4.
It's not as clean, but we do have a nice
open low and then we trade higher before
we close and we take out all of these
targets over here. So, just to review,
if we go back out to the daily candle
here, we have a candle 2 closure, which
allows us to anticipate or look for a
move higher in candle 3. When we go to
the 4hour time frame, we then are
looking for a candle to closure in line
with that on the new day. And here you
can see right off the open, we form a
candle to closure. So then in this
candle three, that's when I'm going to
be looking at the 15-minute time frame
and looking for a reversal to form and
then looking for a new protected swing
to trade that continuation higher. And
this is how you align all of those time
frames together. The easiest expansions
occur when you trade candle 3 on
multiple different time frames. So in
this case the daily and 4hour. So let's
go to our next example and we will go
back to gold a few days. You can see we
have ran out all of these failure swings
into a fair value gap and then we have
what multiple days of expansion. Right?
So we have not had a swing in 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 days. So that is where we can get a
retracement or a reversal. We have a
candle 2 closure here. So what does this
mean? It means I can be looking bearish
in this day or trading candle three
lower. where would I want to see it go
to into this fair value gap below. So
now that we have a pretty clear bias, we
want to go down to the 4hour time frame
and see if we can wait for a candle too
or a reversal intraday. So here we are
on the 4hour and you can see we have
that nice reversal structure, right? We
have a nice sweep of a short-term high
with an aggressive Vshape and a closure
through giving a change in the state of
delivery on this time frame. Here we
have expansion into a consolidation.
We'd want to see this high ran out to
then go ahead and look to trade it
lower. So, let's wait to see if we get a
candle to closure on the 4 hour. This is
not a candle to closure. So, what would
we need to wait for? We need to wait for
a new high to be taken and a new
closure. Here you can see we do get a
candle to closure. We have swept out
this high and then we get a nice
aggressive bearish candle. So, going
into the 15-minut time frame, what do we
want to see be respected? The lower half
of this 4hour candle. So let's go to the
15-minute time frame and look for a
4hour and 15-minute fractal model which
is also in line with this daily candle 3
or an expansion candle. So let's go down
to the 15-inut. So here we are on the
15-minut time frame. You can see our
daily candle. We have anticipated that
this has formed the wick of the daily
candle. And where is a good target? We
could be looking for this previous day's
low, right? That is a pretty good target
to be looking for. And so we want to get
on side before that gets taken out. So,
as we let this play, you can see my
model will print. And what do we have?
We have a point of interest inside that
T-spot area right there.
But here you can see we reach into that
T-spot area into the fair value gap. But
now we need to wait for a continuation.
What would be the continuation? Well, we
look at the series of candles that went
into that point of interest and once we
get the closure through those, that is
when we form the continuation.
And you can see here we get the
continuation lower. We could look to get
on side, put our stop either on the high
or on the bodies that made the high and
then look for 2 R, which is conveniently
right around that low. So, let's see
what happens here.
And you can see we do get a nice trend
lower there. And that is because we are
aligning multiple time frames in one
direction. Right? Our daily is bearish.
We let it open make a high and then
we're getting on side as it's already
trending lower. We have the 4hour make a
swing point we can trade away from and
we're looking to trade in that candle 3
or the candle 4 for the expansion. All
these time frames are aligned in one
direction and that is when expansion
occurs. So this will be a more advanced
example, but as I talked about
previously, I want to align multiple
expansion candles in one direction. Now,
the easiest way to do that is to trade a
daily candle 3 with a 4hour candle 3 and
then a protected swing on the 15-minute
chart. But you can also trade a reversal
candle on the daily if you know how to
do that. And that is where my wick size
video comes into play. But you can see
here on oil, I've been talking about
this a bit on Twitter, but you can take
a look. We have equal highs above here.
And what do we notice? We have this
reversal right here, which happened
Monday of last week. And then Friday, we
do close higher. So, if we're going to
continue higher, we have a weekly candle
that looks like this, right? A nice
expansion candle. So, we'd want to see
it trade or respect 50% of that if we're
going to trade into these highs, which
you can see Trading View Replay already
shows. Going back to the daily chart,
what do we have? Right, we have a down
close candle right there, which forms a
swing and then a nice close over. So, we
wouldn't really want to see price trade
much below 50% of this down candle. So,
Monday opens up. It is a pretty ranging
day or a bearish day. Now, if this is
bearish, we want to see price trade into
previous day low. But if we're bullish
on the higher time frames, what do we
then want to see? We want to see this
previous day low taken out, but then we
want to see price trade higher into the
highs. So, if that's what we're looking
for, we can start to analyze the 4hour
time frame once price reaches into this
level. That's if it has a small wick.
But let's go down to the 4hour time
frame. So, here we are on the 4hour time
frame, and you can see price opens up
and trades lower into this previous day
low, which we wanted to see taken out.
Now, is this a bullish candle? No. So, I
would not consider this a reversal. So,
let's wait for a reversal candle. Here,
you can see we do get a reversal candle.
So, let's go check this out on the
15-minute time frame. So, here you can
see we get our open of our new higher
time frame candle. This would be a valid
continuation if you wanted to try that.
Now, you can see right off the open of
the new higher time frame, this is
starting to invalidate it, right? We
don't want to see it trade below 50% of
this. So, if you were long in this area,
this may be a stopout, right? This would
be a valid entry if you're trading that
positionally, right? looking for 2 into
those highs which would be a stopout.
But if we're waiting for that in candle
change in the state of delivery or the
CID within candle 3 let's see if that
forms
right it doesn't form before taking out
this low. So now we're not going to
change our idea. We're still bullish as
we're respecting the same area. We want
to see if we can get a new candle to
closure.
And here you can see we do get a candle
to closure. What do we notice? This is
also one that you could potentially
trade the reversal candle as we have a
small wick. Here is a continuation right
there. As price reaches into the fair
value gap, closes over. You could trade
that higher. But we're more interested
in trading those continuations. Right?
Our daily candle has a small wick. We're
looking for price to trade into the
highs. So, we can be looking for this
candle three on the 4 hour and then
what? A continuation inside that candle.
So, let's see if that forms.
we do get a bit of a deep retracement
into the lows, which is fine. And I'll
talk about this really quick. A lot of
times when we take out targets, right?
We take out highs. That is when we get
price retracing into the range, either
back into a gap or a lot of times taking
out a previous low that made that high.
So the structure a lot of times looks
like this. I'll just quickly draw this
out. A lot of times if we take out this
target here, we're going to come back in
and run out a low before trading back
higher. But nonetheless, we do what? We
form a continuation. We have a new
protected swing in candle 3. So that is
giving us a new invalidation. So we can
look to trade on the open of candle 4,
my stop on the low and then look for 2
or where can we be looking for this our
higher time frame targets, right? Which
would be this high of day or if we zoom
out, it's going to be those equal highs
above, right? And this is how you get
large risk-to-reward trades is when
you're taking a lower time frame
invalidation and targeting a higher time
frame target. So you can see you can get
over 8R on that. But if we're going to
keep it back to 2 R as I talk about in
my videos, let's see how this works out.
You can see we get 2 R right away. And
let's see how this plays.
And there you can see we do get that
trend higher. So just to review, as this
example is a bit more advanced, as you
can see, we have a nice clear target. We
have equal highs resting above. We know
where we don't want to see price trade
below. And we have that point of
interest. So if price is going to form a
reversal candle, we want to see it
where? Right off previous day low. We go
into the 4hour time frame. Here we have
a 4hour candle 2 closure. And what does
this candle 2 closure allow us to do? It
closes over this down close as well as
sweeps out the previous. It allows us to
anticipate that this candle 3 can expand
higher. But then we can go down to the
15-minute time frame and do what? Look
for a continuation in that candle 3.
Here you can see we get that
continuation and that provides an entry
into this trend higher. As you can see,
it's currently still going. And why does
this occur? Well, if we pull up the
indicator and rewind a little, we are
aligning the daily candle with the 4hour
candle with the 15-minut time frame
trend. So, when you align all of these
time frames together, that is when you
get a trend. Now, before we wrap up this
video, I do want to share something with
everyone who stayed until the end. For
the past few months, I've been running a
program called the lens path with AM
Trades. It's something we've kept closed
off for a while and only allowed a few
of our private members to join. And we
did this because we wanted to build
something that actually worked before
putting it out there for others. So, we
had to see results first. And from this
first small group, we're still in the
middle of the program. We've seen a lot
of past accounts and payouts. So, I have
linked an interview with one of the
traders in the video description below
if you want to hear a bit more about
that. We are going to be opening it up
to the public for the first time, but
keeping it limited. But if you've been
watching my videos, applying the
concepts, and want that extra push with
real structure into your approach, then
this is probably for you. You'll find
more details on what the mentorship
looks like and a wait list to join and
get notified when enrollment opens
through a link in the description below.
But with that, if you did enjoy the
video, please give it a like and
subscribe and I'll see you guys next
time. Have a good one.